va venir maintenant sur toutes les
scènes de Ko et d'affrontement qui a eu
lors des manifestations de ces derniers
jours et notamment hier soir après que
la motion de censure n'est pas été votée
c'est à s'inquiétant mais en réalité le
plus inquiétant c'est au que l'on se
demande même si le pire n'est pas à
venir on va revenir là-dessus bien
entendu et puis surtout on aura un CRS
Grégory Joron qui viendra nous témoigner
tout ce qui se passe actuellement et
puis on aura des audio très très fort de
CRS vous allez voir des audio exclusifs
pour TPMP qui il nous donne voilà leur
sentiment et voilà comment ça se passe
pour eux et c'est vrai qu'ils peuvent
pas parler à visage visage découvert et
vous allez voir que c'est complètement
incroyable le cri d'alerte des CRS c'est
un témoignage très très fort c'est tout
de suite regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci Jean-Sébastien Ferjou fondateur de
l'Atlantico d'être avec nous et je
remercie Grégory Joron CRS secrétaire
SGP Police qui vient souvent de voir qui
va témoigner de tout ce qui se passe
actuellement et c'est vrai que vous
allez voir des scènes incroyables des
scènes de chaos folles juste
je Jean-Sébastien parce que pour les
téléspectateurs on a envie d'avoir
quelques infos pour savoir comment ça va
évoluer tout ça les manifestations
comment c'est tout de suite après que la
motion de censure ne soit pas passée il
manquait 9 voix
et il fallait s'y attendre on savait que
ça allait être le chaos derrière oui
bien sûr parce qu'il y en avait déjà eu
avant après les 9 voix mais je trouve
que c'est très hypocrite quand même la
loi de la démocratie c'est la loi de la
majorité la République elle a été votée
par l'amendement vallon à une voix près
353 voies contre 352 est-ce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon à l'époque aurait dit ah bah
tiens on va rejouer le coup parce que
c'est pas juste pour les monarchistes
donc c'est la loi de la majorité après
après moi je pense que le gouvernement
n'est pas dans un défaut démocratique
mais quand même dans une faute politique
parce que c'est plutôt le cumul des
choses vous savez tous ces articles dont
on a parlé tout le monde est devenu un
peu spécialiste de droit constitutionnel
c'est plutôt le cumul de ces choses là
et on voit bien quand vous avez 93% des
actifs qui sont contre une réforme c'est
un vrai sujet politique donc oui il est
manifestations elles sont d'autant moins
surprenantes qui avaient des gens qui
incitaient en quelque sorte alors on va
regarder plusieurs images qui ont
explosé sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut voir dans ces
images regardez
rien à prendre ici
alors on a vu aussi un policier qui
frappe un manifestant d'ailleurs l'IGPN
la police des polices a été saisi une
enquête administrative est en cours
regardez
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va durer
encore longtemps
oui vraisemblablement puisque scabiens
ce qu'a changé jeudi soir dernier c'est
qu'avant on avait des manifestations qui
étaient très encadrées par les syndicats
l'insert syndicales à vraiment réussi à
maintenir les manifestations qui étaient
globalement paisibles et les Black Blocs
ou ceux qui cherchent la violence ne
pouvait d'ailleurs pas circuler parce
que vous avez un million enfin par
millions par millions de personnes mais
bref des centaines de milliers de
personnes au même endroit c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de s'enfuir là on est
passé à une autre phase où on voit bien
que ce sont plutôt des jeunes très
jeunes c'est l'ultra gauche et c'est
organisé cette organisé on a beaucoup
entendu parler de la stratégie Hong
Kongaise vous savez comme les
manifestants Hong Kong en jetant des
trucs dans la rue brûlant les vélos etc
parce que quand vous vous dissipez aussi
vite que ce qu'on a vu hier soir par
exemple c'est que vous donnez en quelque
sorte des indications c'est pas
totalement de l'improvisation alors on
va avoir une autre vidéo regardez un
manifestant il y a voilà il y a un
moment il y a un policier qui il y a
cette vidéo qui a tourné regardez
voilà je vous dis donc c'est vrai qu'on
a vu plein de images comme ça tournait
sur les réseaux
Grégory on va revenir sur toutes ces
images on va revenir sur des audio qu'on
a de de CRS qui sont qu'il est en 5 cri
d'alerte également ce soir Grégory Jon
c'est quoi la situation actuellement moi
c'est extrêmement tendu c'est c'est
peut-être le pire scénario qui puisse
arriver c'est-à-dire des manifestations
qui sont pas déclarées avec un public
extrêmement jeune très mobile
clairement assez motivé puisqu'on voit
malheureusement l'état l'état des rues
après leur passage et forcément c'est
encore une fois le scénario du pire pour
pour les forces de police parce qu'on
sait pas où est-ce que ça va arriver
comment ça va arriver quel nombre il y
aura il y aura en face et on déplore
depuis 5 jours déjà près de 400 blessés
dans nos rang donc deux plutôt gravement
et surtout des forces de police qui
commence déjà malheureusement être dans
le rouge parce que ils sont déjà
quotidiennement bien bien bien engagé et
là faut par exemple je donne un exemple
précis on parle de CRS faut savoir qui
est il y a deux unités de CRS qu'on fait
24 heures de service d'affilée et donc
vous imaginez qu'après 5 6 heures de
route ils arrivent ils ont une situation
dégradée qui dure une dizaine d'heures
et après on leur demande de reprendre la
route et de repartir et finalement ils
font 24 heures de service donc il y a
des vraies questions à se poser aussi
sur l'état de nos forces nos forces
aujourd'hui et sur l'engagement qu'on
leur demande il y a également des
tensions entre les forces de l'ordre et
les journalistes regardez
[Musique]
c'est un journaliste
d'un manifestant qui attaque un policier
par derrière regardez
[Musique]
incroyables et les CRS au cœur de cette
violence et les manifestations voilà
dégénère beaucoup alors forcément pour
pas
on peut pas bien sûr interdire aux gens
de descendre dans la rue et voilà de de
manifester voilà c'est vrai que mais là
on a l'impression vraiment que ça ça
prend une tournure extrêmement violente
on a une CRS qui n'en peut plus elle
explique à quel point ça peut être dur
d'être face au peuple alors que beaucoup
de CRS comprennent voilà que les gens
soient énervés que les gens soient dans
la rue et le problème c'est qu'il voilà
ils sont devant un dilemme voilà
qui peuvent pas le résoudre écoutez
physiquement psychologique
[Musique]
ouais mais moi je j'ai été CRS pendant
12 ans donc j'ai vécu le CPE les
manifestations forcément engagées oui je
enfin on peut tous se reconnaître quand
on a fait ce métier là dans ce qu'elle
dit après justement c'est important
d'avoir aussi une conscience
professionnelle c'est ce qui fait la
noblesse moi je trouve de ce métier très
clairement c'est qu'on peut avoir notre
conscience citoyenne on est des citoyens
on n'est pas des sous-citoyens on a on a
notre gars là-dessus et on fait partie
des 90 ou 14 % de la population active
qui est contre la réforme des retraites
c'est une réalité sauf qu'après on a un
job et ce boulot on le fait parce qu'on
est professionnel parce que ça fait
partie aussi de d'un métier d'engagement
qu'un métier passion alors oui c'est
extrêmement difficile oui l'engagement
physique je voulais dit et vous voyez
une vacation de 21h j'étais à peu près
dans les clous c'est malheureusement ce
qu'on leur demande et forcément c'est
fatigant et forcément ça peut poser des
cas de conscience mais je trouve que
voilà c'est encore une fois un métier
extrêmement noble et que celui de garder
la paix et d'encadrer des manifestations
est vraiment très difficile en ce moment
dans les rues et que même eux-mêmes les
CRS sont complètement paumés la
situation échappe à tout le monde
écoutez
[Musique]
la situation
elle nous échappe
[Musique]
le témoignage
aussi qui nous a qui a voulu témoigner
vous allez voir c'est très fort oui
Grégory j'ai une question alors d'abord
je sais que vos collègues et vous
travaillent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles donc bravo à tous
les CRS qui sont engagés néanmoins je
voulais revenir sur la première vidéo
qu'on a vu qu'on a diffusé qui fait
énormément de bruit celle du coup de
poing est-ce que là vous trouvez qu'il y
a un usage proportionné de la force
est-ce que votre collègue était
réellement menacé parce que le coup de
poing paraît extrêmement violent je
crois que j'ai entendu le préfet de
police plus ou moins s'expliquer là
dessus en tout cas de dire que
extrêmement rapidement et regardez des
images il avait saisi l'inspection
générale de la police nationale ça
logique pas de sujet je pense que très
vite le collègue sera de toute façon
identifié de toute façon on va
s'expliquer et contrairement aux
fantasmes aussi parce que c'est des
choses qu'il faut déconstruire
on nous fait pas de cadeau sur sur ce
genre de choses faut pas croire dire que
même si des fois la peine peut paraître
douce par rapport au gestes il faut
savoir que derrière il y a quand même
souvent la triple peine quand on est
policier c'est à dire que vous passez en
conseil de discipline vous avez déjà
premièrement une décision de sanction en
fait cette décision elle pèse aussi sur
votre carrière parce que si notamment
vous deviez par exemple passer un grade
vous le passerez plus gras de là et
ensuite vous avez aussi potentiellement
une décision judiciaire donc le policier
il est quand même confronté souvent à
minima et une double peine
administrative et judiciaire alors on va
revenir sur un autre un autre passage
dans les forces de l'ordre et n'en
peuvent plus pour certains il n'y a pas
de solution et le nombre de suicides et
dramatiques écoutez parce qu'elle va
dire cette jeune femme c'est très dur
parce que mon métier c'est que ma
passion c'était ma vie mon métier je
crois en cette police je suis entrée
avec une telle envie une belle passion
j'espère que c'est une maladie pour mon
métier
et aujourd'hui je suis divorcé et
fatigué moralement
c'est celui-ci
de nombreux policiers ici c'est vrai
qu'ils n'en peuvent plus et surtout moi
ce qui revient très souvent c'est qu'ils
disent
on est plutôt d'accord avec c'est ce que
je vous dis à l'instant on est plutôt
d'accord avec les gens qui sont dans la
rue donc c'est doublement plus difficile
forcément oui bien sûr parce que les
policiers sont aussi des fonctionnaires
je pense que la plupart des policiers
sont pas pour la réforme aussi donc
c'est vraiment mais après ils tiennent
leur mission comme tout corps
républicain c'est d'ailleurs de tous les
fonctionnaires ceux qui sont le plus
surveillés le plus encadré le plus
souvent sanctionné mais il y a aussi un
autre sujet vous savez ce sont les
magistrats parce que là en France le
droit il permet les interpellations
participations à attroupement a fortiori
participation à attroupement armé quand
vous avez une arme par destination un
pavé je sais pas quoi vous mettez le feu
à quelque chose en Allemagne vous êtes
condamné pas en France vous avez vu le
cas de cette infirmière vous vous
souvenez l'infirmière qui avait été
condamné parce qu'elle avait justement
frappé un policier dans une
manifestation elle lui avait jeté un
pavé elle a été interpellé dans une
manifestation la semaine dernière jeudi
si je me souviens bien et ben le
magistrat qui a été saisi de son dossier
a classé son suit donc du point de vue
des policiers vous avez aussi cette rage
de constater que les gens qui sont
prennent à eux dans la réalité ne risque
quand même pas grand chose alors que et
c'est normal très normal comme vous le
rappeliez le GPN fait son travail les
policiers eux sont sanctionnés lorsqu'il
y a des dérapages il y a un autre CRS un
homme qui a témoigné aussi pour TPMP il
rappelle une fois de plus qui ne sont
pas contre les manifestants il rappelle
que les cerfs font aussi partie du
peuple écouté
contre l'idée d'un camp les casseurs les
gens violents évidemment que
les manifestations contre cette réforme
sont puisque justifiées encore une fois
on a subi comme tout le monde on suit on
suit on suit la vie de la population en
ont fait partie du peuple
il explique en revanche qu'il ait fait
son travail contre les casseurs et que
pour lui les images que les médias
montrent sont manipulés écoutés
ils sont là pour faire pour [__] le
feu
c'est un peu leur métier donc vraiment
nous tous on fait c'est légitime on fait
ce qui est-ce qu'on nous demande de
faire mais ça reste 7 jours dans la
légalité
on le pêcheur on a des baissé chez nous
mais les images sont manipulées le but
c'est de monter la population contre sa
police on reste à sa police de la
population et malheureusement ça marche
un peu trop bien et
on a appelé tous ces conséquences
très fort c'était moyen pour vous
dévoile ce soir bien sûr en direct dans
TPMP et il y a Elisabeth borne qui est
encore réagi qui a pris une nouvelle
fois la parole aujourd'hui et selon elle
la violence verbale du groupe LFI France
insoumise entraîne ces débordements dans
les rues et ce sont les principaux donc
responsables de ce qui se passe
actuellement écoutez madame la
Présidente hier soir votre violence
verbale à déborder dans la rue mais
alors là
sans surprise vous n'avez plus de mots
pour condamner les violences au
contraire vous continuez sans relâche
votre attaque systém
atiqueen vous vous en prenez aux
policiers et aux gendarmes vous remettez
en quoi
[Applaudissements]
toi et systématiquement examiner
[Musique]
âge il nous protège il protège nos
institutions et l'ordre républicain
voilà c'est bien dit ça et dans
l'actualité justement il y a cet
incident qui aurait eu lieu hier matin
Aubervilliers plus précisément sur le
site Veolia d'Aubervilliers qui a mis
encore un peu plus de feu aux poudres
regarde
d'un policier ce dernier accuse le
député de la France insoumise de la voir
frappé au visage les faits ce serait
déroulé ce matin à Aubervilliers alors
que l'élu venait soutenir le blocage
d'un site de déchets nous avons pu
consulter la plainte du fonctionnaire
qui accuse Eric Coquerel selon ses
déclarations les deux hommes se
faisaient face très proches c'est à ce
moment-là que le député lui a mis en
coup de poing au niveau de la pommette
selon ses dires
Eric Coquerel lui a fait savoir qu'il
démantait catégoriquement ses
accusations il explique et qu'il a été
pris dans une bousculade qu'il a failli
tomber bon alors c'est quoi l'histoire
je crois que c'est ça alors après ça va
être un fonctionnaire assez remonter
face à la parole d'un élu député de
l'Assemblée nationale moi j'ai envie de
dire j'ai un petit parti pris des arbres
quand même forcément non
sérieusement j'ai pas d'argent
s'il vous plaît
tu peux pas les donner
j'en ai pas dis ce que tu penses
encore une fois euh
ses collègues qui sont sur des maintiens
de l'ordre sont extrêmement exposés je
vois pas honnêtement un policier
aujourd'hui quel qu'il soit se faire
plaisir parce qu'en face on a un député
de la France insoumise et dire oui il
m'a mis un coup de poing pour le plaisir
et fabuler honnêtement il sait très bien
que si c'est pas le cas il va être un
peu plus emmerdé que prévu pardon pour
le gros mot mais donc du coup surtout
voilà donc je vois pas trop l'intérêt
donc honnêtement je crois que c'est
assez plausible alors après et de toute
façon il y aura une enquête il y aura du
contradictoire il y aura tout ce qu'on
est dans un état droit et puis la
justice passera et mais en tout était à
cause moi je vais pas remettre en cause
la parole de mon collègue
les images pour le moment toutes les
images qu'on a vu sont pas très
parlantes lui Coquerel dit que il dément
formellement mais c'est vrai qu'on voit
une bousculade et on voit le dos de son
point quand même qui se lève c'est vrai
on voit ça sur les images
Eric Coquerel on voit sur les humains le
policier dit qu'il a été frappé par le
dos du point et on voit sur les images
vous les avez vu aussi le dos du point
qui se lève vers un policier mais on
voit pas le coup donc effectivement il y
a une plainte donc c'est maintenant la
justice qui est Tran donc aujourd'hui
bon réalisé
on va être vite on va être vite fixé oui
mais pour le moment on n'a pas l'image
du coup si vous voulez mais c'est vrai
que vous avez raison d'autres images
parleront évidemment il y a pas les
images mais il y a les paroles la France
insoumise n'arrête pas de dire la police
tu le peuple détestes la police enfin je
veux dire c'est insupportable
c'est des des vraiment des gros
responsables dans cette violence alors
je vais vous dire j'ai des infos tout
droit de quelqu'un de très important
que je ne peux pas citer
pour avoir une connaissance des éléments
de plainte le policier qui dépose contre
Coquerel est formelle Coquerel était en
garde et a frappé du point voilà donc
apparemment c'est les infos que j'ai qui
sont à prendre aux conditionnel bien sûr
c'est quelqu'un qui a accès directement
au dossier quelqu'un qui voilà qui qui
connaît bien le le le le dossier voilà
donc je vous dis voilà après bon on
verra bien sûr ça mais ce que dit
Géraldine toi Géraldine c'est c'est fou
ce que tu dis toi tu toi tu es d'accord
avec Elizabeth rappelez-vous ici de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon face à ce policier
extraordinaire de la BAC inquiétez ceux
qui la menacé qui lui a dit si moi je
suis président ça se passera pas comme
ça et tout ça bah voilà il y a une sorte
de détestation de la police complètement
démago qui est insupportable et qui est
très très dangereuse et moi je pense
qu'effectivement du coup ils
instrumentalisent la jeunesse qui
veulent casser qui veulent brûler tout
ça et c'est catastrophique voilà aussi
parfois parce qu'il faut bien le
comprendre c'est pas que des Bizzbee
entre personnes ce serait qui serait
énervé c'est qu'il y a une partie je dis
bien une partie de la France insoumise
c'est pas toute la nuit c'est évidemment
ce n'est pas toute la France insoumise
non plus mais qui veut l'insurrection et
bien sûr
il pense que c'est un peu maintenant ou
jamais et donc il souhaite
l'insurrection il pense que là il y a un
moment pour le jouer donc quand vous
dites la police tue c'est pas juste
parce que vous essayez de séduire des
gens qui auraient eu à faire à parfois
des dérapages policiers parce que ça
existe ça peut arriver heureusement de
manière très limitée c'est parce que
vous entretenez l'idée que la police en
institution républicaine n'est pas
légitime parce que le jour où les
Français sont dans la rue parce que
justement le jour où protection
arriverait on n'y est pas je pense qu'on
n'y sera pas d'ailleurs mais bref le
jour où elle arriverait et ben vous
aurez déconsidéré ceux qui sont des
facto les remparts de la République et
les remparts du régime et c'est ça qui
se joue c'est pour ça que c'est très
choquant la police tue et il y avait
aussi moi je m'en souviens j'avais
trouvé ça immonde les suicides et vous
vous souvenez les manifestations pendant
les gilets jaunes notamment il y avait
une rue près de la gare Saint-Lazare il
y avait des responsables de la France
insoumise qui étaient présents qui
peut-être ne criez pas eux mais ils
étaient présents et quoi qu'il en soit
ils n'ont pas éprouvé le besoin de se
distinguer de tous ceux qui étaient face
aux policiers et qui leur criait suicidé
vous quand on sait le nombre de suicides
qu'il y a dans la police pardon mais ça
n'est pas une étiquette vous en voulez à
la France insoumise ou pas non parce que
je pense que quand on a une parole
publique et c'est d'accueil d'ailleurs
le cas de moi ce soir je pense qu'il
faut justement essayer de pas attiser
les haines c'est ce qu'ils font eux très
bien je pense que c'est pas toujours
républicain c'est une certitude moi je
vois de nombreux policiers que je croise
dans la rue qui qui me parle et qui me
disent que voilà que que c'est c'est
compliqué pour eux parce que justement
aussi voilà les discours certains
discours font que voilà les gens ont
sont chauffés à être avoir la haine
je partage quand même cet avis là c'est
à dire qu'à un moment donné justement
ils ont quand même la responsabilité de
transmettre des messages des messages
des messages qui sont quand même forts
parce que quand on est président de
groupe
candidat à la présidentielle X fois et
3e dans les résultats c'est pas anodin
et quand on s'exprime c'est quand même
plutôt entendu et quand on a ce genre en
effet de propos qui sont extrêmement
claniques et qui mettent juste les gens
dos à dos je trouve qu'il y a quand même
une semaine parce qu'en réalité pardon
la vraie question qui se pose c'est oui
il y a pas assez d'heures de tirs on le
sait il y a pas assez d'heures
d'entraînement Grégory djeron disait
tout à l'heure des compagnies qu'on
travaillait pendant 24 heures d'affilée
vous imaginez bien tout le monde est
humain policier comme n'importe qui
d'autre Eric Dupont-Moretti est bien
capable lui de s'énerver de faire un
bras d'honneur à l'Assemblée nationale
on demander de l'exemplarité aux autres
quand ils sont épuisés c'est un peu mais
donc le vrai sujet quand ils disent la
police
c'est-à-dire qu'on est un truc qui est
très important c'est qu'effectivement en
septembre de quoi Jean-Luc Mélenchon est
un révolutionnaire il va faire la sacrée
République et veut une révolution la
révolution ça se fait dans le sang en ce
moment il pousse les gens dans la rue et
c'est dangereux parce qu'à un moment il
faudra apprécier surtout peur pour les
gens il faudra rendre des comptes que je
dis il y a un moment il faudra rendre
des comptes quand tu pousses les gens
dans la rue il y aura des gens qui sont
blessés peut-être des morts c'est très
dangereux ce qu'il faut il y aura du
sang sur les mains vraiment tu viens de
dire un truc j'ai peur pour les gens
parce que moi je pense que bien sûr un
livre qui va se préparer le 23 mars et
contrairement
je suis d'accord sur le côté sur la
France insoumise mais ce serait une
erreur de penser que c'est que la France
insoumise bien sûr le bol de tous les
français bien sûr moi j'ai des gens qui
ont voté pour Macron qui vont aller
manifester le vainqueur
la réforme des retraites il y a 90% des
bien sûr c'est la goutte d'eau attends
je finis juste ça c'est pas les gilets
jaunes c'est pas des des personnes de 60
ans qui lèvent les mains et qui se font
tirer dessus bêtement vous avez dit
c'est des manifestations qui
s'organisent comme ça à l'arrache pour
pas être dans la nasse vous allez voir
que c'est moi j'ai très peur je suis
comme toi Cyril moi j'ai très peur qu'il
arrive un drame avec une vie qui va être
perdue d'un côté ou d'un autre je sais
pas mais je pense que j'espère que le
gouvernement a bien réfléchi pour
maintenir ça et pour pas dire je
suspends selon timing parce que le
timing il est catastrophique je pense
que
c'est pas les gilets jaunes là
Jean-Sébastien vous avez démarré vous
avez démarré cette séquence en disant
euh c'est la démocratie c'est la loi
c'est comme ça maintenant ça y est la
motion sur les 9 voix le soir
c'est la règle c'est la règle du jeu
donc aujourd'hui il faut on fait quoi il
y a plus moyen de revenir en arrière le
gouvernement reviendra pas en arrière
bah ça a été fait Macron dit demain je
ne crois pas qu'il souhaite revenir mais
je dis c'est pas moi je crois qu'il faut
respecter la démocratie représentative
il n'y a pas d'autres moyens que de
respecter la loi de la majorité même si
elle parait injuste en revanche comme je
vous le disais en revanche comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure là on est dans
autre chose 93% c'est le contrat social
et le vrai sujet c'est que je pense
qu'on est en train de basculer d'une
crise qui était circonscrite à la
contestation de cette réforme là sur les
retrait es à une crise systémique en
quelque sorte comme les gilets jaunes au
début c'était les carburants
totalité notre modèle économique et
social et même
merci à tous merci à tous